Her low freak bitches at a video.
But you,
so Eddie,
what do you,
you don't think that like t rex is a real,
do you really that when you look,
when you look into,
uh,
when dinosaur bones or first to Scotland,
a marijuana meme that says,
when you look into dot,
dot,
dot.
When you're looking at the timeline,
it wasn't just like,
oh,
all dinosaurs were discovered.
There was a timeline.
There was a lot of,
there was a lot of fraudulent shit that was dude's like,
hey,
look what I found.
There's not bitch.
That's just a whale bond that I fuck never getting paid.
There was a little of fraud going on in the 18 hundreds when they were
discovering the birth,
but was that,
what about like the,
the way the earth is like the layers and you can tell certain time periods from
the layers of the stratus?
Well,
if you're talking about carbon dating,
there's a lot of science that goes back and forth.
Like it ain't shit or it's real.
Oh,
it's not the job.
The most universally acknowledged a carbon datings effective.
Okay,
well not the stuff that I'm looking into.
I don't know.
I looking on youtube,
man,
don't take my word for
this shit.
Be Crazy.
Chase your tail with this shit,
man.
No,
I'm not.
I'm having fun,
entertaining,
and really love it.
He loves figuring out how we're being bullshitted is very,
I'm obsessed with it.
They bullshitting us.
I love that.
See,
I like
people like this.
I think this is a crazy idea.
I think we're being lied to about fucking everything.
Your Kid's going to grow up just saying skeptical.
Fuck out.
I'm already telling him.
I'm already telling him don't trust anything you see on TV.
I'm Martin though.
We don't let him watch TV.
Let them watch a little cartoons here,
here,
and there.
A little bit.
Bunch Bob's corrupt as,
but I'm going to raise him not trusting TV.
You know I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
You can't.
You can't say nobody would ever disagree with that.
That is,
TV is not good for kids.
Not good for kids.
Why don't you have a show on the Alex Jones Channel?
What has happened?
I agree.
What the fuck?
I went total retard on them.
I wouldn't full flat earth on them.
No,
no,
no.
Most,
most,
most conspiracy,
they think flat earth is the most retarded thing ever.
When Joe first just correct when Joe first brought it up about a year,
year and a half ago,
he said,
dude,
he was trying to,
he was,
he was trying to basically say how stupid people are.
He said,
do you know if people still believe the earth is flat and the sun is 3000 miles
away?
And I remember sitting there thinking,
shit,
that what are the Amish or something like how dumb do have to be to connect the
world?
That slash no nothing.
And then you brought it,
you brought it up again like maybe six months later.
And I,
and I said,
on your podcast,
I said,
that's got it.
That is so dumb.
That's gotta be some kind of CIA Cya.
It's going to be some kind of disruption.
Go Weird left.
And then I was in class and one of were,
we were talking about conspiracy
theories and my f,
my buddy Manny,
full blown conspiracy,
they shift to cleanse us.
He goes,
do you ever do have my Jujitsu class?
we're talking about my youtube class.
I was conspiracy class.
No God,
you go to school teachers.
I teach and I know that
people had to kill a
bright man.
He turns me.
Cause did he ever look into flat earth?
This was like eight months ago or something and I said when he said that,
he said that you ever look into astronomy.
Yeah.
Right when he said Danny did you must fourth grade,
right when he said that I dropped you on your head,
I,
I locked.
I can't believe anything that ever comes out of his mouth again.
That's what I stopped my Jesus and I'm like,
please don't ever bring this shit up again.
You keep that shit dude.
Cut to do that.
Since the turn around,
another guy comes,
I'm telling you the story.
And then,
and then earnest comes up to me and he goes,
hey man,
you ever look into flat earth?
Jesus,
God Damn Christ.
And he goes,
hey man,
I got a master's in engineering,
look into it.
And I just wanted to go.
I just went home and I was just going to,
how about them?
Under what fucking school that was.
We didn't tell people
Phoenix online and shit like,
hey man,
shit know I'm so crazy.
I so don't believe anyone else to do I.
I tried to,
I tried to debunk it.
I was trying to debunk it.
I was Mr Donkor,
there's a fucking Japanese satellite that takes a photo from $22,000 worse
commodities.
Japanese though,
even if the pixel is all fucked up,
those pictures put up the Japanese pictures from 22,000 miles away.
You remember pictures?
Do you remember when you bought the phone?
I can't remember when you got a flip phone dude and you,
you're the front facing cameras were always dog shit always,
you know,
on the back face he won.
It was pretty legit.
Yeah.
That's how it works for 22,000 miles away.
It's a hard to take that iPhone seven have you ever seen a picture of it?
Hold on.
No,
I didn't say that.
The crazy thing,
I'm not saying it's flat,
I'm just look into it.
I'm saying we don't know what the fuck wrong.
Wait a minute,
Eddie.
This Japanese satellite,
hold on.
Eddie.
This Japanese satellite that all these hundreds of scientists worked on,
they take the moon land picture every 10 minutes and you can download it from
the website.
So Gi composites,
so constantly making CGI in some sorts of,
some sort of a cognitive bank somewhere.
Contact.
They do it in NASA.
NASA.
That's what they do.
Why do you think they have the technology to make CGI?
That looks that good.
Why don't they have the technology in the space?
What's the pictures from Massa?
How come they don't have any,
they don't have that space.
Kind of that kind of a technology.
No,
they just never did it.
They also don't give a fuck about proven.
That's round shadows pictures.
I've seen him show me.
Show me a real quick,
listen.
NASA does not have one of those satellites.
Why do you think that's fair?
Why does it look?
It looks like it looks like something you'd see in a movie.
That's because when they do it in a move,
they try to make it look like this,
which is what it looks real.
If that's real team and you don't think it's real,
they faked six moon.
Moondance stop saying that because it's irrelevant.
We're not talking about,
looks like it looks fake to me.
Eddie.
That's 1969 we're talking about 2017 so you think there's some gigantic
conspiracy involving the Japanese government where they put up a fake picture of
the Earth from 22,000 miles up every 10 minutes.
High resolution,
downloadable photo.
Why wouldn't it be your real,
what?
Isn't it just as likely that the Japanese actually did launch that thing in this
space?
Why would it be fake propaganda,
man?
He cared that it's stays there.
A photo of this flat earth.
No,
I don't.
I like I just said again,
there's is there's phone,
there's no photo of,
of the flat earth from space.
There's no photo of the round earth.
That's not true.
All felt those.
Why do you say they're fake though?
It's CGI,
but you're not an expert in imagery.
It looks fake to me.
Convince you though.
When I watch Avatar to be an expert,
to know what's tar.
Advertise at the movies and you watch some ridiculous Kung Fu video beat a
martial arts expert.
If you were sitting next to someone that told you that their Sensei can't
compete in the UFC because they're too deadly,
when you get pissed off because you're an actual martial arts expert,
that's just like you with no science background whatsoever.
Talking about photos,
I know crazy like that.
I'm crazy,
but why not indulge at all?
It's crazy.
Why not indulge the full realm of possibilities and not clean to the conspiracy?
Every single time
NASA can get pictured,
they've been,
they've been doing CGI composite but pleasing this whole question.
I forget about stating what NASA does.
Please answer my questions.
Why do you always go towards the conspiracy?
Why do you never consider the possibility that maybe they're not the same
people?
So everybody's lying.
All the spit European space agencies like all in on it.
It's a global thing.
I think all governments,
uh,
most of them,
the globalists are all working together to,
to control there.
What's the advantage?
That it's not round.
If they control you,
Bro,
fuck with [inaudible] keep you on up.
There's,
I don't know,
man.
I don't know what it doesn't make sense.
Why wouldn't they make sense?
Why he just controlled by,
in a sense you could find the sentence.
The real is that you put them on a ball because again,
I'm crazy.
You put them on a ball.
My guesses.
You're on a ball.
You're nowhere.
Don't try to go anywhere.
Just stay down in the,
Oh hell no.
We sat down and said,
you know what?
We've got to release some fake math that shows that you can demonstrate that the
earth is round.
We've got to release patch earth from space.
What does that,
we just looked at one at.
He stopped saying it is fake.
You don't know that it's fake,
but you're saying look,
it's a real problem when you say,
but don't say that.
Just stop.
Just stop and think because you're,
you're communicating to millions of people and you're saying something that
doesn't make any sense.
It does make so you don't know anything about imagery.
You don't know anything about what?
You don't know anything about that.
It looks fake to me.
You don't have come on and you're just looking at it with the naked eye.
It looks real to everybody else in this room.
Someone that I with a confirmation bias.
Crazy,
right?
No,
I don't think he made sure he was having fun with it.
But you don't direct inclination to always go towards a conspiracy.
Does it keeps your opinion?
It's a disservice.
That's what you think.
Cool.
It doesn't have to like you're getting angry.
No,
I'm not getting any at all.
The stoners,
stoners,
I'm like,
I don't believe that shit.
I'm not raising my voice when I'm trying to do is corner your ideas.
I try to corner your ideas because you're saying these things to you very
influential and you saying these things to millions of people,
but I don't think you're thinking correct.
I'm telling,
I know.
That's why I've stated many times that you're crazy.
But here's the bottom line.
When you use it,
when do you think you started losing it?
I think I was,
you know,
as soon as I found out when I was 11 that everybody wasn't Catholic.
That was,
that's when I started losing my,
wait a minute,
I'm like,
everybody's not Catholic.
I thought everybody was Catholic.
There's other religions and how do we know we're right?
There's a bunch of,
what's a Jew?
Oh Shit,
there's more Jews and Catholics.
How do we know we have the right religion?
I'm like,
okay,
yes.
That's when I started going Chris.
So funny.
People to question authority are usually looked at as crazy conspiracy theorist.
The CCIO coined the term conspiracy.
You're a smart dude yesterday.
There's a problem in the way you approach these things cause you approached them
all knowing before you even start that there are conspiracy and telling you
what.
So that's confirmation bias.
I'm telling you,
hey dude,
when you lie so much,
you've got to prove it to me.
Utilize so God damn much.
I'm never going to be saying the things that a defense,
but you don't hear what I'm saying.
The thing I the prosecuting attorney with solid time.
That's what I'm saying,
but it's not a good analogy because it's exactly how I look at.
Filled with lies allows governments,
governments,
uh,
on uh,
being accused of lying.
I understand
they're in court and the government,
not the government.
Oh,
whoever,
whoever.
Just in general scientists,
it's all government scientist.
You think scientists,
you think there's these independent scientists come.
It's all government scientists that I'll try to,
why would she?
Grants are all
the control.
You don't think,
you don't think the globalists aren't control having control the science and
information since day one was like a new thing there.
Name the globalists.
They'd be like,
yeah,
it's flat.
It's flat enough.
Fuck,
these guys are globalists.
None other global.
This is what it's called.
Eddie slipped me if we just spent like a day to get there.
I think he just tried to have fun.
Hey,
I'm just having fun man.
I like finding I get is I don't trust shit and coming from the government.
Does that make me crazy?
You know the problem problem is this idea
of the government.
The government consists of a bunch of individual science agencies.
Eddie,
you know they have score fighting.
Do you know like the CIA and the FBI go after each other.
There's no one governments,
a lot of personal shit going on in between of course,
but it's not just personal shit.
There's a bunch of different factions that you call the government and the idea
that it's all like the government can't be trusted.
I just say that cause I'm not gonna.
I mean you want me to pick out some agencies got NASA.
I could pick out some sadness deck but just in general in general,
it's history,
science,
education,
energy.
Everything has always been controlled by the government.
Since day one,
radio has been used as propaganda since the day it was invented.
You think some independent dude just invented radio and then he started
broadcasting that like his favorite music and shit and he what his thoughts?
No,
it was the government from day one and radio.
It was the government in all countries from day one in uh,
uh,
TV and the movies.
It was the,
it was all radio,
TV and the movies.
You remember always been about propaganda.
Always in every country.
It's nothing new.
It's old school gangsters are countries the most,
what does this have to do with the world?
This is this,
this,
this is how gangster,
ah,
are,
uh,
government is,
there's a,
there was a war on drugs.
We started wanting drugs.
Turns out we're bringing it in.
Then there's a war on terrorism.
Turns out how do we create it?
Al Qaeda.
You understand why I'm crazy.
I'm crazy because of that shit.
I'm like,
you could believe that shit.
You want to believe that shit.
You just apply this to everything.
It basically,
anything comes from the government.
Anything coming from the government.
Dinosaurs don't come from the government.
Just,
there's so much fraud when you look into government scientists.
Let's get into it.
Look into it,
but I have looked into it.
Look,
this is,
you could,
you could go over these different sessions of the earth that look here,
we can look at the next one that comes 10 minutes later.
Maybe you won't think that one's fake.
Like,
Oh wow,
that one's kind of right.
It's all fake.
It doesn't look fake to me it looks like what the fucking earth probably looks
like when you're 22,000 miles away to you.
It does not to me,
but can we agree to disagree?
Yeah,
but why think that it does?
Because I don't trust shit.
Why think that?
I don't trust the government does make these fake pictures of the earth.
Don't you think that would be like we could speculate.
You want to speculate?
I mean I could show you.
I want to hear your spectrum.
It's easier to control people when they're on a ball.
I've been trying to tell people that forever.
I don't know.
Like we got to live in a ball.
I told it to my wife.
It's a bit easy to get the kids to listen.
I've just slipped on a ball from his house.
Bull Shit.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what to believe.
That doesn't even make any sense.
Why would it be easier to get people to listen to throwing a ball rather than
their fun a plate?
Because if there's more land,
people going to want to work,
there's actually more land shit.
What do you mean it's more land?
It might,
who knows if if you,
um,
exactly,
what are you talking about?
I don't understand what you're talking about.
Like more or less.
If the world is flat and the flat earth model is true,
what's the point of it?
What's the point of so all the math is fake on the earth is going 24 hours in a
circle.
Is that all fake?
That it spins and it was miles an hour?
I don't,
uh,
when you look at a stationary,
haven't screws.
There's,
if you look into the experiments,
if you look into the experiments to prove that the earth is spinning,
all of them failed.
Look into it.
We've been indoctrinated him.
No,
no,
that's not true.
That's not true.
Okay.
I'm crazy.
I get it edited.
Well,
Jamie,
just,
I don't have the science in my head to back it up yet,
but that's not true.
You can't say things like that.
That's what Eric Dubay says,
and he's not backing it up.
Where's the evidence that find the evidence?
There are kids in high school right now that can show you the evidence with
science if you can't show it to me because I'm not in class right now and I'm
not up to date.
I'm doing jre work.
Right?
Okay.
You're talking about some middle weren't on camera.
You're talking about some shit,
but he,
you're saying I don't trust it.
You're saying something that people have been proving for hundreds and hundreds
of Nicholas Mickelson Morley experiments.
That was,
uh,
Einstein said it himself.
Einstein said to this day,
Einstein said,
don't worry,
no proof that we're moving.
Do you guys just have them do it?
That's all it is.
There's a difference.
You'd look into it and watching youtube videos.
So,
so let's say this,
okay,
so one gal channel,
okay?
What if it's true that Albert Einstein said,
there is no evidence that the earth is spinning.
What did he say?
He said course.
You said,
that's not true.
I saw it on Youtube,
but what if we find out that it is true?
Then what?
What if they find out leprechauns are really but fucking genius.
I thought that was,
I mean that's what I said.
So you're saying,
Oh,
do you really
look at what maybe a 1947 there wasn't much evidence of the Earth is spinning
because it didn't understand it yet.
Okay.
When we're talking about something that happened more than a half a century ago,
Einstein is,
look,
he compare all the people that are alive today,
whether it's Lawrence Krauss or Stephen Hawking's,
most famous field experiment.
That's the mic.
What does it morally experiment?
It was under,
couldn't recreate it.
It was an 1880s I looked this up when I was watching him.
Listen to what he just said.
Exactly.
You keep using that.
Look at the Mickelson Warley experiments I did.
I ran up the information on it.
It's an experiment that was supposed to be able to be recreated.
It was not able to be recreated.
So you,
that evidence is used by flat earth supporting people.
Like you just said,
like go look it up.
Go look it up.
Look it up.
Repeatable.
You can't repair it.
You don't understand.
That's what you're saying.
I'm trying to tell you that that's the evidence you're trying to say.
If they save the experiment showed the earth
is not spinning,
no one can reproduce that experiment.
That's why it's not real.
So this thing that you keep repeating is bullshit and this thing that you keep
her but don't.
No,
no,
no.
Did you get this Information Jeff?
Jamie,
where'd you get it?
When I get what?
This information,
what does this come from?
This is coming off the Internet.
Exactly.
American.
So I'm reading some information.
I'm reading some men.
Go to the library
sources here.
There's a book called the American Journal of Science.
I'm sure that which is bought and paid for it.
Well,
maybe it is.
It's awkward.
It's part of the Washington Post.
Why would anybody be paying money for people to lie about the world's
very good question that everybody asks coming in.
Everybody off the group have a seat.
They're not,
they're not huge.
Not getting knocked down.
That's why we just read this thing that you've been siting and you didn't even
understand it when we were reading it.
You read off the Internet.
That's how I read it.
I don't have any books here.
We're both getting our information off the Internet.
So you were saying is peer reviewed journals from science,
from American journal offense.
Come on.
That's like,
so you think it's more likely more likely that everyone is in on it and lying
than it is.
One guy doesn't know what the fuck he's talking about and it makes a youtube
video and you get convinced and it's attractive to you because it seems like it
would be an amazing conspiracy to be ahead of,
and you get trapped in the fucking rabbit hole and you'd go down to flat earth
rabbit hole and you find yourself defending things with experiments you don't
even understand,
which means you just let some shit that he pulled up off the internet and I know
you like all over it.
I know you didn't understand it twice.
It doesn't matter.
But I understood it and he had explained it to you twice and you didn't
understand that you were our,
no,
no.
This is the proof of,
now I understand there was an experiment to prove that the earth wasn't moving
and lead them and then they,
and then they proved it,
but it won't.
But no,
no,
no.
I get,
they didn't prove it,
but that doesn't mean that it's spinning.
Oh,
Jamie,
I'm sure you can find some evidence of the Earth is spinning.
Eddie.
People who have known it's spinning forever.
That's how you,
that's how the seasons,
where would he be?
Happy.
You see the sun we spin around.
That's why it makes a claim this to this.
Why we,
that's where you can track time zones.
That's where he could put a piece of stick in the ground and it after seeing all
the connections that it acts as a Sundial,
you're saying,
oh the Shit Eddie.
There's a said there's a fundamental problem with the way you approach these
things.
Problem.
The problem is you do.
It's not that I try to shit,
you know I don't trust you.
I don't.
It doesn't matter.
That's a flat around it doesn't matter.
That's all back.
You keep saying that it's a bad fallback because what I'm,
what we're saying is there are conspiracies.
The problem is when you think everything is conspiracy,
you act as a cyop guy and you fuck people over that want to look at real
conspiracies because the real conspiracies,
the Gulf of Tonkin.
That's what I thought.
Ticking like the Gulf of Tonkin.
Real,
real like operation Northwoods real things that really happened.
When you look at those things and people explore them,
they go,
oh,
I don't think they really killed Kennedy.
Are you sure?
Why don't you look at this?
Look at this stuff.
There's a lot of really crazy evidence when you start thinking that the world is
flat,
that dinosaurs aren't real,
all this nutty shit that you believe and you just jump into it with the problem
is it discredits all these other things that you believe that might be real
because the other things have some validity to that you just haven't looked
into.
That's all Ed.
I used to say the Sandy,
you're talking about the earth being flat.
That was,
I'm saying the same thing.
You can do what you think they're all wrong.
That's so insane.
You haven't looked into it.
I have.
Oh my God.
How could I not have,
you don't think I have.
I'm watching you go down the rabbit hole.
You don't think I've tried to pay attention to what the fuck these people are
talking about.
It doesn't work.
I don't think so.
At any of there's websites dedicated to debunking.
It is dedicated to showing you the science,
showing you the math that you can detect them.
When you check the Internet.
It's valid,
but when I'm on the Internet it's not,
you're not talking about the internet,
you're talking about a guys youtube?
No,
it's an oh guys.
There's a lot of guys.
There's a lot of people,
but they're just youtube.
No science behind them is not verified by peer review journals.
The science of the Earth,
the Saudi government science that's bought and paid for.
Of course,
you start talking about this,
so you just have third is flat.
I didn't say that.
I said,
I dunno if it's flat or round.
When I see a picture of earth from space,
what we're sitting on from space.
When I see a real picture,
then we'll have the proof.
I'm just saying we don't even have nerves going.
It's round.
No,
we're looking at pictures while we're sitting here.
Okay.
You,
you're not even taking into consideration the fact that this is a monitor that
you're looking at this.
You're not.
It's,
you don't even get like the high resolution.
I mean they must be gigantic files that they get.
You would never be able to see him and their actual resolution on a regular
monitor in the first place.
You're talking about a photo of the earth photo of the Earth from 22,000 miles
away and they take one every fucking
look CGI to you.
You'd have to jump on a ship.
You know your side could be wrong.
It could be real.
Too many things could be real,
but they've been faking them so much.
They look like all those other fake what's not as good as I've seen so many fake
ones that NASA,
a mitts that they're CGI composites.
There's so many out there.
So when you see this one,
it's like this is the same one.
Yeah,
but facing so many people,
and this is the [inaudible] composites is different when you can pay.
I don't believe that.
Eddie,
please,
when you take one of these photos,
these,
what are those calls?
When you fucking do that,
when you do that,
you know what that is?
That's a composite.
You're taking a bunch of photographs and they piece them all together.
It makes one enormous photo.
When you see these photos from space of the earth from a closer saddle,
not the NASA one that Jamie just pulled up,
which does show a full full size image of the earth.
What you're seeing is they take a photo,
they take it on the front and they piece them all together.
There's no scenes him composites?
No,
no.
There's an actual CGI.
Put them together,
get colors,
everything in Eddie,
is this CGI it question for you,
is this CGI because it's con,
it was made in a computer and it fits the definition of computer generated image
because that's the composite one could easily mean made this,
I'll show you.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying,
but this could easily a real picture,
but it is a real picture.
That's not a hard picture.
Where I wasn't sure of earth from space where I physically was on the ground in
New York City and take that with the camera I was using.
That building would not fit in my lens.
I wasn't far enough away,
but that's not what they're saying they're doing.
They're saying they take strips.
That's what,
that's what they're saying they do.
They're saying,
I'm going to show you a video of the artists who actually did the latest one.
They go,
oh NASA,
here's the guy who did the latest.
Tell us what to look at it.
Let's watch a video.
Just put NASA artist a CGI picture of earth and you're going to hear him talking
and he says it did his Photoshop.
It is,
it is Photoshop,
but it has to be fought a shot.
He says that word for word because it's so massive asking you to,
I would ask you to clarify that.
I'm trying to tell you that that's what I literally had to do.
I had to have been farther away to get the photo in one photo of that giant
building,
but that where I have in order to get that distance away coloring with CGI,
there were buildings in the way.
You're saying that it in Photoshop.
I put it into Photoshop.
He's going through the video going,
I got it cause I got up.
I was,
sometimes I put green shades here and I kind of,
I'm not an astronaut,
I never been to space,
so I have to kind of use my imagination to taking black whites
that NASA releases of earth.
Here's the latest one like this that day that's a little exaggerated.
The dark weren't that dark in real life.
The brights aren't that bright and real life.
So yes,
I added color to it.
I did some artistry to it,
but that's bull shit.
So we got the fucking building looks like.
Oh,
okay.
Now find that the CGI artists,
do you believe anything?
I believe shit that I can prove for myself.
Like I believe the science in like a skyscraper,
skyscraper it standing there.
That's true.
But how am I believe in that?
How much have you looked into like the science of space travel?
How much have you looked at how much work was done to try to put satellites into
orbit?
So you'd think we went to the moon.
That's not what I asked you.
I said,
how much did you look at the,
he answered my fucking talk.
Ridiculous.
So he's trying circle you talking in circles.
They're ridiculous conversations.
Everything is the government,
the government,
the government's fake pictures.
Why don't just ask you a question.
Punch up NASA.
CGI artists.
Picture of earth.
I don't see that up there.
The head.
He's so crazy.
Which one would you like me to click on?
Any of them?
That one right there.
The second one right there.
I mean,
that's just listen to him talk.
Okay.
Steering has 20,000 well,
it's going to get more now.
Today I want to share with you this article.
Are we allowed to play?
This guy isn't a scientist.
Are we listening to him or the the guy that made the video,
you said we're gonna listen to a scientist.
Well,
I forgot what it looked like.
The right video.
I don't know.
Look at the guy that is the artist and
he has,
this is the,
that's a picture of the video.
He's talking to him,
talking about how he created the latest picture of earth for NASA.
They're celebrating
Goddard.
It's from the Goddard webpage.
So he's doing a recap of something that's written on the God or webpage,
so go to the God or webpage,
find that guys page Robert and Photoshop.
There it was and we'll see what he's actually saying.
Is that it?
Picture?
What do you think is the most interesting that your role here at Goddard?
How do you help support God's mission?
My role is to make imagery from earth scientists,
sciences data.
I turn data into pictures.
I looked for new interesting events and Natalie NASA satellites have seen or
that are hidden in the latest data to anything interesting that shows off.
NASA is unique capabilities.
Finding things is the fun part.
I rely on engineers and scientists to produce the data.
They're reliable.
Real time stream of 1.7 terabytes a day.
Holy Shit is incredible terabyte.
The same as producing 3000 cds a day.
We know where to look for the interesting stuff because each instrument provides
a very specialized type of information.
So if I'm looking for something specific,
I know where to look.
For example,
recently there was a volcanic eruption in the Red Sea.
The only reliable imagery of this was from NASA satellites.
We basically confirm the existence of a new island.
Okay,
so where's the,
let's get to some Photoshop shit.
The one where he's talking.
Okay,
but this guy's talking about science here.
Like some of the sites have to be real,
right?
Eddie?
Like there has to be some subtle,
it's like direct TV.
Direct TV's not fake,
right?
Um,
I don't know.
But you could do all that with landline stuff.
You don't need to go bounce anything from space.
You could do a lot with my,
wouldn't you?
You could just put it in space and it just broadcast and shoot it up there and
shoot it back.
Why would you lie about it?
That means there's a ton of fucking space junk.
They satellites,
faith for satellites.
No pays for satellites.
The taxpayer,
they,
they get bills.
We need nude telecommunication satellite.
We got to throw it up there.
So you don't need $35 million don't think.
And they go,
yeah,
okay,
we're going to sign it.
They get the money to tax scam.
You don't think satellites are real?
I don't think so,
but Jesus Christ,
I don't think so.
Well,
what's happening?
What about,
what are those things up there that you can watch from the ground?
Have you ever seen the space station fly overhead?
You can see it.
They can take pictures of it.
The time that they told me it was going to be overhead,
I took a picture of it and everyone was in a high altitude plane.
What's the difference?
Why would they do that?
Why would they lie?
Why would they pretended to space?
How high do airplanes go?
30,000 feet.
Right now they can go hire 50 plus commercial airplanes on average,
I think just somewhere in the thirties 30 35,000 right when you're on the
ground,
you could barely see it when they're at 30,000 feet,
barely fucking.
When you're in therapy 30,000 feet and you look down,
you wouldn't be able to see a god damn.
It's true bus or a plane.
Now those satellites are supposed to be like hundred miles up.
Think about that because they're in space and there are light.
There are small pinprick
of light that moves across the sky.
You could see him with optics.
Okay,
do you want it?
but you really haven't looked and you definitely haven't looked with optics.
If you look with like a big spotting scope,
these people get these telescopes and they look up and they know exactly what's
going to be.
You can actually program it into the telescope.
There's things that you can download where you could find the coordinates of
itch in the each individual planet.
The way these really super powerful telescopes use amateur astronomers like to
use.
You Punch in the key numbers and it'll move specifically to a spot in the sky
where you can tune into the moon or tune into Saturn or into very specific areas
of the cosmos that change all the time because of the fact that the earth is
spinning.
We're catching all sorts of different shit all,
all sorts of different times.
Especially no matter where you are,
if you're on the equator,
you're looking at a totally different image,
you know at one moment in the sky,
then you are the next moment.
So it can tell you exactly where the space station is going to be,
where the moon's going to be,
where Mars is going to be,
and they punched these coordinates into these little computers and they all move
to this thing.
You believe the Marvel Mars rover,
Israel,
man,
Eddie,
I don't think I'm going to do this anymore because it's just like I don't see
why.
First of all,
I don't see the money.
Hold on a second.
I don't see where the money is to have all these hoaxes that you don't see the
tax scam with Dalit Rovers and they get the,
they just got nine NASA got $19 billion,
uh,
for Trump.
Gave him $19 billion.
What tells any possible so that they can actually make a rover?
Tell me what,
tell me what the space shuttle has done for humanity.
Tell me all that money that was wasted on spacial and then they just trashed it.
They went up,
I don't know how many times and then they just trashed it.
I don't tell me how all those billions of dollars has helped humanity.
Tell me.
Well,
I think scientific innovation is very important to us because in our minds we
constantly want newer bed,
better,
more innovative technology.
Just a part of being a person in the 21st century what everybody wants.
Everybody wants a new computer,
everybody wants new things and a lot of this new stuff comes from NASA
technology.
It comes from all the science and innovation that's goes names part of me.
There's a list right there,
but why do you say this when you don't look into it?
I just love telling highway safety down [inaudible] that how can we can caddy
but the,
the massive requirements that you have on the gear when you're talking about
going through fucking space,
the insane stress of reentry,
they figured out all kinds of crazy shit that speed and which you land.
They figured out a bunch of crazy shit and rich baby food,
I mean portable,
cordless vacuums,
freeze drying technology.
All this comes from space.
There's a shit load of things that they figured out.
Harnessing solar energy.
There's a lot of innovation that comes from the development of either the space
station or the shuttles or a bunch of different things that they've invented and
they continue to innovate these things.
These new satellites they're shooting out in the space are way better than the
Hubble.
They keep doing more and more,
better and better.
And it's this constant rush to see who can get to the,
the furthest point of technology in whatever field they're in,
whether it's the field of rocketry,
whether it's the field of satellites,
there's this massive amount of competition between the top scientists in the
world.
And to think that that's all fake doesn't make any sense because there are some
things that are fake.
So why assume that all of this technology is fake when you really could see the
challenger,
you saw the challenger explode in the sky.
If it's fake,
no one was there to engineer the shit that failed.
Who said that was fine?
Well,
any of it,
any space travel,
because this place is going up.
It's still high altitude.
You know,
the space shuttle goes up and they work on fucking satellites.
I do know that the space station is the video that
maybe hit it.
They do this.
The problem is,
is a lot of these things that you just automatically want to fake six moon
missions.
Dude,
of course I don't trust show Colin females.
Even if that was true.
Those are people in 1969 did not the same humans.
Uh,
so some people,
they're not the same human beings.
That's just like saying that the people who made the movies in 1969 are the same
people that made fast and furious.
Eight is that they make the movies.
They're not the same people.
They're totally different humans.
It's like saying the standup comedians from 1969 were the same as the one that
was [inaudible] 69 they fake six moon missions.
How am I supposed to believe those are not the same people?
Even if that was true,
there's not the same people in rich.
Richard Nixon isn't alive anymore.
He just write them all off though.
Eddie to to me,
I don't need to believe,
but don't need to believe it.
How's it going to add on?
Believe it.
But if it's true,
I don't give a shit.
Okay?
It's true.
Oh,
that's true.
Okay,
but you got to prove it to me.
Otherwise the problem isn't die handled.
The problem is there's no proven it and you want to always assume that it's
fake.
You don't have like this empty,
prove it to me.
Like I'm not assuming either way.
You're assuming it's fake.
Every time they fake six moon missions,
it doesn't matter.
These are not the same people living in a different type of people.
They want,
they're not going to understand the logic.
The logic is just because someone fakes something one point in time before you
were alive,
doesn't mean that those same human beings ever managed to download their brains
and everybody that ever did that job for the rest of time,
because they're not the same humans,
but so that he'll be the scientists that are today,
the generations later,
whether it's NASA or these Japanese scientists or the Russians,
the Chinese,
whoever the fuck is putting satellites and rockets into space,
they're not the same people from 1969 okay.
You can't like look at him.
It's like in one ad,
one blanket organization can't,
I can't blame NASA in 1969 [inaudible] NASA,
uh,
Warner von Braun at Nazi.
I can't blame today's NASA for all the lies from,
is that what you're saying?
From the early seventies?
I'm saying,
do you believe that the space shuttles were real?
No,
I do believe the space shuttle.
Why?
Just that?
Yeah.
Why that I've saw plenty of video of them landing and just man,
and that's it.
And everything else
is bullshit.
No,
they made the Saturn five rockets and they launched him.
Okay,
so you don't know where they go into orbit when the orbiter,
I don't know how high,
how high people are going.
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
You don't know?
I know they're going high,
but I don't know how high.
So why would you assume that any of it is fake?
They fake six moon missions.
Okay.
You keep saying that.
No,
but that's why.
Yeah,
but we're talking about the same people at ea,
but that's,
but it doesn't matter.
It's the same organization.
The problem is turned them into VA as soon as you say they but did not know.
Let me,
let me ask you a Brendan,
do you see that?
How I can't trust NASA because even though it was different people in 1969 to
1973 even though the p the massive today aren't the ones that fake six moon
missions and stole billions of dollars from American taxpayer just because the
guys from today,
somehow they got weeded out and then NASA,
I don't know that they got weeded out in a,
NASA became this honest agency of the government,
but I don't know that.
I'm going to assume,
I'm going to assume no,
I think you're,
you're,
it's still part of the sandy.
I could be wrong.
Let's say those six missions were all bullshit and it was fake.
You're going off the exception,
not the general rule.
So it's like me coming into your academy and some guy's a dick.
I'm like,
all those 10th planet guys are Dicks.
Like you're just lumping all them in the same fucking,
that was a big shit though.
Wasn't like side project mass employees.
This is no,
I understand you saying the same thing he said.
He's saying that just because,
dude,
that was,
you don't seem to move soon.
So gigantic and so global and the greatest achievement of mankind and they don't
even have the records anymore.
Joe,
you know what I'm talking about?
We're talking about this earlier,
man.
You were talking about this early.
You know all that moon imagery data's missing.
They had an awesome video says,
he says,
yeah,
we don't have it.
It's missing or maybe it's stolen,
but even if we did had an asset,
even if we did have the tapes,
we don't have the machines to play him anymore,
so it really doesn't matter.
Come on man.
At the dumbest retard detective on the planet would would be suspicious.
That just like mission,
but you can't just lump all,
oh,
it's all bullshit.
Then anyone with the most,
you want to see something,
Brendan,
it'll make you think this is the most suspicious thing.
One of the weirdest things about the moon landing is the post flight press
conference.
Have you ever seen it?
It's really weird.
It's real weird.
That would make sense.
The conspiracy hippos,
skeptical hippos.
What the fuck is going on?
You guys are open to the doctor.
Maybe they faked it because now you're going,
you're open to the fact that maybe I,
maybe they did fake that,
but you can't just lump,
and I'm saying the greatest achievement of man,
we got new people now.
Come on,
man.
That's hilarious.
How can,
can you see how I can't trust shit from asset
that
maybe they would,
they they,
they,
you know,
all those bad people have died and there are old and the new NASA there,
the good Massa,
they can't all get to believe that
there was an agenda or believe in a guy on youtube.
It says the world's flat and dinosaurs aren't real.
What's better if that was mom's space like that,
it's,
there's a lot of people saying [inaudible] all those guys.
There's a lot of people in mental institutions,
a lot of people in jail.
So how do people that are child molesters?
There's a lot of racist people.
Those people,
if you gave every racist person a video camera and put made them a youtube
video,
you'll be like,
oh,
have you watched all fit with racists?
Have you watched history of flat earth by Eric?
Can I see that?
How long is it?
Oh No,
don't have an hour for that.
You're asking for from
their side.
What does Eric do?
Band in
fourth grade.
My teacher.
I know what you don't care and that's fine.
I'm not going to be mad at you for not caring.
Of course.
Don't be mad at me for carrying.
Then
you don't look into what scientists,
why you getting mad?
Cause you don't look into what scientists say.
You don't.
You just automatically dismiss them all this.
Correct.
Is this fair to say the reason why you care so much about Eddie believe in this
shit and you know Eddie going on crazy cause he said he influences a lot of
people and you enough for yourself.
Look for the truth.
Look into it like uh,
like you're investigating and just look into both sides.
There's a reason why it's becoming huge.
There's a reason.
Yeah,
because people don't really go to school.
They don't learn astrophysics,
they don't study all these things.
It's hard to learn the bay.
The entry barrier is fucking huge.
If you want to study physics,
you want to figure out how to,
I can't,
I can barely pay attention to it.
I listened.
He's books on tape and I have to go back over him three,
four times just to understand a paragraph.
Try to figure out exactly what the fuck they're quantifying.
They're talking about really intense shit that thousands of people who've been
working on in conjunction,
they all feed off of each other's innovation.
There's so many people working on these things.
Eddie,
the idea that they're all in on some sort of a giant global lie is insane.
Yeah.
That's what everyone thinks.
Okay.
There's no,
I mean that's,
there's no
history of flat earth looking,
doing no.
Definitely no.
Why?
I don't watch game of Thrones,
game of Thrones.
I don't watch breaking bad and better call Saul.
Nope.
What do you watch?
I watch real shit like first 48 and you're not talking about a show,
but if you watch his game of Thrones,
he knows it's fake.
It's fake.
But you don't,
I,
I'm just having fun.
What do you think?
Is the earth flat around?
I don't know if it's flat or round until we see a picture from space.
They're saying this bitch could be squared around.
It could be what?
Full ABC camera with fish.
I fish.
I bet you guys are fooled by the Fisheye Lens.
C'Mon man.
Was plenty
of pictures without the fish.
I had legs.
Did you could find this fish
basic ass kindergarten.
Do you understand perspective?
I do understand that high.
If you didn't have a fish eye lens,
you're looking at this tiny fraction of the surface.
The reason why they do some 1946.
How do you know that's real?
Because it's a picture.
I read it on the Internet.
That's why I know
Eddie,
would you be open to talking to you?
That's real.
I don't care.
Would you be looking in to talking to an actual astrophysicist?
Yes.
I would love to.
Like what would you do if Neil degrasse Tyson was here?
Same arguments,
but would you listen to him like you've yet to be told you some shit that
actually made sense or what'd you just think?
He's a Pardot.
I round Earth Society.
I think.
Uh,
he's um,
you know,
there's people that they push to be the spokespeople and there's really
brilliant people that are good at talking and their educators like him.
And then they get on television and people love it.
And so he comes back and then he does a hit show called Cosmos or reenact the
Carl Sagan show.
And everybody loves it.
And more people understand science now than ever before because he breaks his
heart.
Eddie,
you know,
it's hard because you got to go to school for this.
I'm not mad,
but look,
I love you man.
I love you.
You know,
I'm just done.
I'm just trying to,
I want to,
I want to be able to talk about flat earth and have fun cake,
but it's not fun for me because I think there's some 16 year old kids out there
that are listen to this and they think he makes sense.
And the problem is the,
what's wrong with that?
Who cares about,
because those poor kids,
what's happened here?
Me Am I am I,
my life is going to wasting time.
No,
it's heavy.
You're wasting time.
You fucking come on.
Come on and he'd do it.
All this shit.
They do waste time.
You would consider a waste of time.
If someone was all in poor Paul and he was obsessed with poor,
you would say,
you're wasting your time.
What are you getting out of?
When I hit those walls,
they're real.
They're real.
I hit those balls to go into the whole,
it takes skill and concentration and I,
it gives me something to occupy my mind.
It's a game.
It's a mind game and it's a body game.
When you're watching a fake video that guy made about,
you think it's fake nuclear bombs not being real.
It's fake.
Hmm.
Okay.
That's what to think.
I mean,
I just feel like,
oh no.
The
people that study it at all the universities have come to a conclusion and then
one guy makes a youtube video or 20 guys,
they're saying a thousand Santos Bonacci why did,
why would you listen to them versus stability freaks,
generations after generations of studying the science behind it.
We're comfortable science repeatable.
Right,
but you just told us about this one test and you parroted it out as some sort of
a theory that we should look up and when we did it turns out it didn't even
work.
It wasn't repeated.
You okay,
whatever.
Eddie,
I love you,
but I don't like the way you approach these things sometimes because I think it
confuses the fuck out of people like I was when I was young.
I was
super gullible.
I believed all kinds of stupid shit and I wasted a ton of time.
Like what?
Especially with successful guys,
all these goddamned Ufo people,
man,
all those I'll Yulia Ufo stories I bought and all that.
She never got the,
have you ever heard of the law of perspective?
Yes.
No,
that's not real.
That's not a law went about it.
It's that that's the deaf they're giving the definition of what perspective is.
No,
it's a law perspective is,
I'm trying to tell you though real quick.
There are laws of conservation of energy and such in physics.
There are actual laws that they can be translated without even speaking
language.
It's math.
The law perspective is not one of those,
what is it?
Tell me.
It's just,
it's just a definition of perspective.
I'm asking you what the law,
what is it?
Cause it's not really,
well,
maybe,
maybe.
So you're saying there's no uh,
love.
I'm saying it's not a law like gravity.
It's a definition of the word perspective.
That's not a law.
Well,
the laws of perspective are the Herat one of the loss she has.
No,
there are no horizon of perspective.
Our real high level,
that's eye level.
That's not how it always happens.
It always happens.
Not a law,
but it always happens.
It's the law.
If it happens,
that's not a law.
That's,
this is where you don't understand part of the laws of science.
That's not a law.
That's a definition.
Okay.
And then finishes,
what is the definition?
Definition of a noun.
It's a person,
place thing or idea.
That's not a law.
Okay.
That's just the definition.
You know what else is,
I used to call this double lotus for years and years and years.
And it's not double lotus.
It's full load.
It's not a lot though.
Right.
But it's not,
it's not double loaded snow a,
it's not double load.
So that's what you're saying.
You're talking about a different word for the same moves.
They move what he's saying perspective Stephanie Shot Better because,
okay,
hold on.
It's the same thing because of whatever you call it.
God,
Allah or you want,
well when you look up this stuff online,
I try to type in the law perspective cause I wanted to see what your,
what you and Eric Dubay believe that that is the only thing I ever find with the
law perspective is the words flat earth with it.
Or maybe there's actually the urban dictionary has a,
has a different definition for now.
What does it matter if it's law but it's not a lot.
Definitely say matters but that,
but if the horizon always rises,
not lie level,
that's not a lot though for that up.
Uh,
uh,
what would you call it then?
Um,
you don't believe in gravity though of perspective.
I don't believe in gravity either.
That falls at a constant of 9.8 meters per second.
That is a,
that's a law of gravity.
Gravity is a theory I had not,
no,
no.
You guys have a theory of what gravity is.
Density,
but that's another scientific word.
You guys said that if it's more dense it falls,
but why does it fall?
Why was it fall over?
If it's deserts heavier than,
why is it heavier?
Do you know what?
Cause it's tense.
We're only shortfalls.
Helium.
Hocoma helium gas.
Helium was a gas.
We're only heavy.
Lighter.
Then it's the oxygen.
It's lighter.
It's less dense.
I'll explain it's lighter because we're in the atmosphere of earth.
Isn't it less dense than if we were in space?
There is no atmosphere.
That's why everything floats.
Gases and us were dense too,
but we would float in space just like get floods.
We got into space.
You're correct.
If we got out there,
so can we not go to space?
I don't know how far we can go up
the space station.
You said the space shuttle went into orbit.
I don't know how far it went.
How high.
I don't know where it went,
but I know it took off.
Saw that and then I see it landing.
You see that more?
I went on a plane,
right?
For sure.
Are you not confused on what laws and stuff science are though?
Do you not see that?
Okay.
We'll call it definition,
but what do we call it?
But that's not,
what did we call it?
We'll call it whatever you want.
In science,
we call things laws.
We don't call them definitions and science.
There are laws because?
Because so what is that?
That law,
which is most of them
called most cases,
it's math.
Hold on.
In most cases it's math,
the law so that that math,
then that formulaic equation can go to any country and work.
I don't need to speak English to the guy in Germany.
That to explain to them what I'm trying to get out of it,
he can test it with the same things,
the same variables and get the same thing out of it.
That's why all these things are laws.
Not Definitely.
Thank you for clearing that up permit.
Does that work?
Do you accept that or no,
but uses verbose terminology because it makes them appear smarter than they
really are to make some cross.
No Eddie and they tried to say it in a fancier way because they really didn't go
to school for this shit.
So they say a bunch of shit that's not real.
Like the law of perspective and it's not a law and it belies the real problem.
They don't have an education,
this stuff,
and they're just talking about of ass.
That's disrespectful,
disrespectful to the fucking generations of people that had been studying that
their whole lives.
That one guy can figure out all these different things that dinosaurs aren't
real.
Nuclear bombs are real,
the earth is flat.
It's ridiculous.
Satellites aren't real.
It's one guy is the smartest person in the world.
Well,
the one guy that one guy that you're pals with,
love that stuff.
That guys got videos on dinosaurs on the fucking earth.
Figured it all the time now.
I had him on my podcast.
That's the most money he makes off to flatter it's I'd be interested in,
now that he's writing a lot of books off and a lot of youtube videos,
isn't everybody making money as a NASA making billions?
Well,
he's a guy with a youtube account.
NASA lied six times about the moon missions and I don't believe we could come
back from that.
That's it,
but that's the root of it all,
so don't be mad.
That's why we should understand that.
That's one of that is because of that
posture's idea available that every photo of the earth is fake and there's,
there's no photos,
there's no videos
of the composite.
Special video.
Find a problem that there's no photos of the earth being flat,
not there's no photos of the earth being round.
There's planning,
there's no,
NASA will tell Nasa will tell you that about CGI artist.
How can we,
how do we skip over that?
I think we can't get any,
NASA can't even get a picture.
That doesn't mean that is
was never goes back to that for me.
It's like they didn't see anything in there about CGI that that article said.
He puts together data and make the photos.
He puts together data because it has to be interpreted because you're talking
about 1.7 you said [inaudible] video of him talking to the video.
You told me to try it was,
that was the wrong one.
All the fights are a terrible bunch where he's talking terabytes like a thousand
gigabytes.
There's a word for word.
He goes,
well,
it is.
It's photoshopped it.
It's Photoshop.
It has to be.
It's,
it's not,
I don't know shop.
You didn't say it in that article,
but he did.
He did said come out of his mouth.
He's got to find the other thing.
But when you're talking about you don't,
Photoshop doesn't mean that they're distorting the image.
It also can mean that the connecting a bunch of different images to make,
but when you watch him talking about how we put together the official picture of
earth from space,
he's talking about cartoon animation type Shit.
He's talking about his own imagination.
Well,
maybe because he's talking about this insane amount of data,
1.7 terabytes,
maybe we don't understand how the fuck that gets interpreted into an image in
the first place.
I don't even know if it's possible to do it.
You know like to have an in perspective when you're looking at it like a 12 inch
screen or 24 inch screen where the fuck your monitor would be and you're going
to take this 1.7 terabyte image and shrink it down so it fits in there.
I don't understand that messed with some shit.
That finished product is it admitted CIA,
CGI composite.
It's admitted.
It's not even.
All of a sudden the Japanese got real ones.
The chaplain,
he's got real ones,
but that's again figure it out.
Oh Eddie.
NASA does have one.
That's what the problem is.
They keep saying they don't from 1972 they were saying the only real one that
happens for like two minutes pulled up is up right now that there's pictures
from today that discover when you said throw some pictures.
Okay,
you guys,
it was way cool.
Why
six times leaving the space shuttle,
but you don't believe in anything else.
That's where it ends.
Shutter goes up and flies around direct TV.
I don't want it does dinosaurs.
I don't know.
Here it goes.
This is just,
that looks fake as fuck.
April 16 2017 anything.
You guys taught stuff
all the time.
You have to fake ones off.
It looks,
it looks just like the ones that were admitted there were fake.
Let's say that let's stop of thoughts,
but they look exactly like the ones that were admitted.
Fakes where you accepted we was real.
Can I send you to space and like what do you need to fuck with?
You want to see something that's real man.
His ass up.
I see
a bunch of fake ones in the show me that one I got that looks like all the CGI
ones.
I say I don't believe it.
Let's try to stick this land.
Damn,
this is a motherfucker of a pocket.
Jesus.
I worry about Yeti.
I really do.
We don't need to,
man.
I'm fucking group better than ever know.
You have no idea.
I worry about you going down these rabbit holes and thoughts.
What's what?
What's the big deal?
Who cares if the earth is round or flat?
It's entertaining to me.
I understand.
So what's the big deal?
Who cares if,
yeah,
if kids start looking into flat earth,
good start questioning shit.
If you look into it and you,
and you have proof that it is around,
instead of going,
oh,
some scientists figured out,
somebody figured it out,
somebody figured out.
But you figure it out.
You try to figure it out.
You know,
the one thing that all we know that we don't need scientists to figure out as we
know a couple of things.
A compass,
a compass points to north.
It doesn't need a battery in it.
If there's no wars.
No,
no,
I know.
Let me,
let me explain it.
This is all we know.
There's all,
we know it's pointing to the north.
There's um,
it's,
it's a magnetic force in the north.
That's all we know that for sure.
I don't need a scientist to confirm that.
I know that there's a force in the north,
some kind of magnetic force.
What else do,
what else don't I need a government scientist confirmation from uh,
uh,
the north star.
It's right over the north end.
We finish,
let me finish.
Let me just finish.
Let me just finish the North Pole.
The North Star,
Polaris is directly coincidentally over the North Pole where all the campuses
are pointing.
All the company companies are pointing to the North Pole.
There's this a magnetic force in the North Pole and coincidence Polaris.
No,
I'm just saying it.
The Polaris is directly over the North Pole.
It has been multiple north stars is Polaris directly above the North Pole.
You know that there's been more than one northstar over the history.
Where'd you get that information from?
From the Internet.
Exactly.
So you don't believe that any,
I don't know.
I mean it's Polaris Star,
Polaris,
the North Star.
Let me read this please.
Cause you explain right now,
Earth's rotation access happens to be pointing almost exactly a Polaris,
but in the year 3000 BC,
the North Star was a star called through ban,
also known as Alpha draconian and in about 13,000 years from now,
the procession of the rotation axis will mean that the Brightstar Vega will be
the north star.
That's according to NASA.
That's according to every scientist that studies at Eddie from.
How do you know that?
Because that's why it's still a,
how do you know every night?
How do you know?
You just said you don't know list.
There's no dispute about this.
I bet.
I bet he Jamie could pull up 100 different fucking things.
It'll show you the same thing on the Internet,
but it's not just on the Internet and it's okay if you just hit the internet,
but it's not okay if I get information.
It's an information war.
That's what it is.
It's do you get your information?
There's no information on both sides,
but it's okay.
You don't think that's true.
You look it up and now when I look at it,
northstar changes over time.
University of what does that Michigan,
does that make sense?
That doesn't make any,
that's not science.
Why does that not make sense?
No,
I said it doesn't make sense that the Internet only works for you and not
familiar what works when you,
when you keep them looking at it over,
over and over again from
all these multiple sources.
Wouldn't you just assume you said over and over and over.
You didn't say,
you'd said over and over and over and over,
and then you did.
What are you playing games?
This is like you're playing tic TAC toe.
You're not looking at the truth like a little GI Joe.
If you want to believe NASA after getting all the fakes six,
it's all government side.
I'm telling me then why does that compass point towards the north?
I don't know.
We,
we know.
We know it.
There's a magnetic force in the north,
in the magic in the North Pole.
Right,
and we know the Polaris is right over the north pole and the constellations
rotate around Polaris.
Polaris is a fixed star and they all wrote the constellations,
rotate around that and it's right over the North Pole.
Spent
how much time you've actually spent
explaining what,
what did I say wrong?
You and Eric Dubay repeat that over and over again.
Like the sky doesn't change at night.
No,
no,
I didn't know what I said.
I never said that.
I said,
you said North Star.
Does the Polaris star stay ahead of the norm over the North Pole?
Yes or no?
And do the constellations rotate around Polaris?
Nope.
Yes sir.
No Sir.
Don't rotate.
No,
no.
They spin around.
When you look at time lapse photography of Polaris,
you could you go watch the time.
All the constellations gone.
Polaris is the fixed her.
That's why they can go.
You're not,
you could find your way around and just find the north star.
It doesn't move.
Explain that.
And if the Earth is spinning like we know it is,
what's directly above the earth would stay the same because the earth is
spinning faster than spaces.
Earth is spinning a thousand miles an hour and a circle.
Even though the cosmos suspending the cosmos changes as well.
There's a lot of things that change
and the sky looks different all the time.
Change right over the North Pole.
But if you were spinning and you're talking about a small window of time when
they're taking these time,
life time lapse photographs,
they're taking over a few hours.
Yes,
but he would do you understand that?
That if you looking up over a few hours and you have one light that's directly
overhead and the other ones are circulate,
the one light that's directly overhead over a few hours is not going to move
enough to register in the photograph,
but the ones on the sides are,
when you're looking at a timelapse,
you're looking at a time lapse over a few hours.
If you were looking at a time lapse over months or years,
you would see that thing spinning too.
Polaris would still be on the same spot.
No.
You'd have the procession of the equinoxes.
It changes the rotation of the earth.
Earth wobbles on its axis.
They've been tracking that
forever.
You're going to watch time will last photography on your,
on Youtube.
Do you know you're not listening to one time lapse photography is over a few
hours and then over a few hours you can see the Earth Connie,
thousand miles an hour and constellation circling around Polaris.
That's one motion,
right?
You,
you capture one motion and that time lapse photography,
but science is telling us that there's four motions going on.
There are.
They're just much slower.
You're talking about something that you're looking at it.
It's very quick.
Over a very short amount of time,
year after year,
decade to decade.
Polar look up.
Same spot.
None of these stars are staying in the same spot.
You got to find one a polar.
Why would I pull a specific one that you're looking for?
Find Polaris
and everything's going around Eddie.
Eddie,
what are you looking at right there when you see that,
that time lapse photo spinning,
right?
The earth and the sky is,
is this guy spinning or is the earth's what do you think?
I think the sky spinning.
Jesus Christ.
Why would people be lying about that?
I think,
I think
right.
There's Polaris,
right?
You know why?
Because it's in the center.
Ready?
Yeah,
exactly.
There's always that 32nd picture.
No,
you talking about something that happens very.
All those other constellations are moving really quick.
Eddie.
If it's the ones directly overhead.
Okay.
If you have a ball and you spit it on your finger like Michael Jordan,
the outside equator of the ball is going to spin like fucking crazy and this big
long wide loop,
but the tip of the ball is going to spin in a very short,
tight circle.
Okay.
Right.
When you see the Harlem Globe trotters,
you can test it yourself.
Eddie,
if you just point a camera in the same spot out of your window for like three
months straight,
take a photo,
maybe even four or five tests.
I'm talking about [inaudible].
We just give you an example to test it for yourself to show you that the stars,
the stars in the sky that you'll see above your head like you've claimed to go
out and look out every night will be different throughout the year.
No,
no.
They won't be different.
They're moving.
They are rotating,
the are rotating around.
Polaris not going to be in the same spot.
Taking the are moving.
Okay.
They are moving,
but you're always going to see Polaris.
Why would you think that this is a conspiracy?
Why would they lie about the earth spinning when it's really the the universe
spinning or they're not stars trying to control.
I don't know.
What are they?
I Dunno.
People,
LEDs.
People looking down.
GRANDPA happy people,
their souls.
Angels.
You're telling me my grandma's other flying unicorns,
bro.
Grandma's flying Unicorn came and told you the crazy.
Oh,
you don't do shit.
None.
No.
Chris,
the craziest shit can't tell you crazy.
Crazier.
Why save it?
I don't
have I how already making fun of me for Flat Earth.
I remember I'm trying.
I just don't,
I just don't trust NASA.
I understand.
You had a circle of trust or some crazy shit.
Please promise me end on this
crazy,
crazy t shirt for next time.
Yeah,
just don't make it.
If you drop it now,
we'll never make it out here and cut.
It's six o'clock.
I know.
I just want to,
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Six o'clock.
Unless,
unless you want to hear it now.
I don't know if should,
it's too crazy.
It's too crazy.
Let's go do it.
Okay.
Chris taught.
We'll talk off here about this.
Crazy.
It'll discredit the flat earth theory.
I can't hit my mind.
Can't handle daddy everything spirit.
I left this one.
You need a tissue says everything is conspiracy
you make.
You will make Alex Jones look like fucking like Gandhi.
Fuck yeah.
Like Alex Jones is like Alex Jones,
like 90% of conspiracy theories.
Like,
wow,
that's all bullshit.
You know?
But Eddie,
just these fucking,
yeah,
you,
you got to appreciate the hustle by adding does lack a bluebell.
Percy Paris.
You'd have the,
wow.
I can't believe you said that straight.
Let's end on that.
Okay.